[CLOCK TICKS]
Does it ever bother you; having to take care of me?
Nah. [CANE SLAMS] It makes me feel special.
I'll restore the optical properties of the right eye.
You'll be able to count fingers on day one. By week 4, you should be at 20/50!
May I have you count backwards from ten?
-Ten...
Nine...
Gina?! [DRAMATIC BOOM]
[SOBS]
I can see! [BOTH GIGGLE]
♪ I may not always love you ♪
♪ Love is in the stars above you ♪
♪ You'll never need to doubt it ♪
♪ I'll make you so sure about it ♪ [DRAMATIC BOOM]
-What's going on?
-I just feel like I know everything... but now I don't.
[CHUCKLE]
Never seen my wife in a dress like that. Guess it's not really you, huh?
Well, we don't really know who "me" is, do we?
Who is the guy you were talking over there?
[GIGGLES]
[THAI WOMAN SPEAKING THROUGH EARBUDS]
[inaudible]
Did you love me more before?
You were blind?
I could ask you the same thing.
♪